[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau point
sur l'actualité locale comme chaque jour
voici les titres de cette édition du 2
mai c'est l'une des dernières zones
humides continental d'ile-de-france la
réserve naturelle de saint quentin en
yvelines ouverte voici 33 ans elle se
penche sur la perception et
l'appropriation des visiteurs nous en
parlerons avec nos invités
après trois ans de travaux le musée du
jouet à poissy va rouvrir ses portes une
rénovation complète que vous découvrirez
en avant-première dans quelques instants
et puis c'est aujourd'hui la journée
mondiale du scrapbooking quelques
conseils en fin de journal pour vous
lancer dans la décoration notamment des
albums photos entre collage et découpage
mais pour débuter ce journal la suite de
la mobilisation des salariés d'une
entreprise de limay qui dénonçait la
semaine dernière les pratiques de leurs
supérieurs selon eux des manquements
graves à l'environnement seraient à
déplorer
alors que leur entreprise doit justement
collecter et assainir des produits
dangereux
la direction régionale et
interdépartementale de l'environnement
et de l'énergie a fait le déplacement en
début de semaine elle a constaté que
l'entreprise svr devait réaliser une
dépollution de ses locaux et bien
qu'aucun danger grave ne soit à déplorer
veolia propriétaire de la filiale va
mener un audit en interne et se
désolidarise de ce comportement
transport et sécurité à présent faire du
vélo en toute sécurité grâce à des qcm
des parcours sur circuit le code de la
route avec savoir rouler les enfants de
6 à 11 ans après n'a circulé en
autonomie sur leur deux roues un
programme lancé par le gouvernement
auquel la fédération française de
cyclisme a été associé plusieurs jeunes
ont pu passer une étape de leur
attestation mardi dernier c'était au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines leur montrer
que utiliser le vélo ça nécessite des
compétences des compétences pour savoir
évoluer dans
dans le cadre de la route qui est
partagée avec d'autres utilisateurs les
voitures mais aussi les trottinettes les
piétons et puis c'est savoir manier son
vélo savoir évoluer en sécurité ça veut
dire savoir être à l'aise avec son son
support vélo j'accueille en plateau à
présent joannon glas de garnier bonjour
cette conservatrice de la réserve
naturelle de saint quentin en yvelines
et quatre anneaux bonsoir vous effectuez
votre service civique au sein de cette
réserve une réserve qui mène jusqu'en
juillet une étude pour évaluer est sa
perception et son appropriation par les
visiteurs on va en parler plus en détail
c'est vous qui menez cette enquête en
quoi ça consiste déjà dans les grandes
lignes alors oui c'est moi qui minent
cette enquête
alors en fait dans les grands amis cette
enquête est là pour objectif un peu
dévaluée l'ancrage territorial de la
réserve naturelle et d'avoir un peu la
vision de ses usagers donc à voir lors
leur perception du lieu comment ils
comprennent les missions concrètement de
la réserve naturelle savoir s'ils sont
attachés à ce lieu
et voilà avoir un peu toutes ces idées
là en tête donc être conservatrices de
cette réserve ya aucune étude de ce type
qui a été menée depuis trente trois ans
maintenant
ben c'est totalement inédit
effectivement il ya eu des petites
études qui ont été faites à l'occasion
d'un projet
voilà ou alors très ponctuel mais de
cette envergure c'est bien la première
fois et ça servira à quoi pour vous ça
va vous servir ensuite donc ça nous sert
à construire l'avenir enfin se dire
qu'on regarde le passé en
on veut interroger les gens les gens qui
sont déjà venus sur la réserve naturelle
donc ils la connaissent et on veut leur
poser des questions pour qu'ils nous
disent eux pour eux la réserve pour moi
la réserve c'est ça nous ce n'est pas ça
alors justement dans les grandes lignes
parce qu'on va pas donner tous les
éléments de réponse puisque si les gens
souhaitent souhaitent y participer aussi
mais cette réserve qui a maintenant 33
ans quelles sont ses missions jusqu'à
présent alors les missions des réserves
déjà dans le réseau des réserves
naturelles de france 1 c'est bon quand
même de protéger les milieux naturels
donc cette mission elle le fait sur ce
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 33 ans
au coeur de l'agglomération à
l'intérieur de l'île de loisirs de 50
ans donc
ça c'est la mission qui nous occupe le
plus et donc une réserve naturelle se
visite
et donc c'est pour ça que des visiteurs
sont déjà venus nombreux la visiter il
ya 230 espèces d'oiseaux oui alors oui
un peu plus maintenant que ce qu'on
évalue chaque année voilà le nombre
d'oiseaux qui passe sur le site en
termes d'espèces et donc on en est à 260
ça fait à peu près un mois vous avez
lancé c'est cette étude va se prolonger
jusqu'à cet été jusqu'au mois de juillet
jusqu'à présent les retours que vous
avez pu avoir
alors pour l'instant on a quelques
réponses au questionnaire et les
réponses soient assez positif c'est à
dire que pour l'instant ce sont surtout
les personnes habituées qui ont répondu
et les personnes et notamment les
étudiants et les personnes hors du
secteur de l'or nitot qui peut vraiment
la fréquentent
et ils nous ont vraiment expliqué qu' il
était vraiment très attaché à ce milieu
mais pour le moment il nous manque
encore beaucoup de beaucoup de réponses
à un questionnaire pour que ce soit
vraiment représentatifs faut vous
arriviez a j'imagine un certain nombre
de réponses ou le plus possible vraiment
le plus de réponses possible que ce soit
à 100 200 300 400 peu importe vraiment
le plus ça sera le mieux pour nous sur
la méthodologie comment vous allez
travailler jusqu'en juillet ses de la
collecte
ensuite quelle chance quand vieillesse
et de la collecte donc là il ya un
questionnaire donc qui est disponible en
ligne donc dure entre 10 et 15 minutes
et qui pousse un peu les répondants à
réfléchir sur leurs habitudes et voilà
comment ils perçoivent la réserve
ensuite il va y avoir une phase une
phase de dépouillement et une phase de
traitement des données donc jusqu'en à
peu près septembre où on pourra enfin
proposer les résultats aux personnes
pour qu'ils voient eux mêmes ce que l'
enquête a day et ça vous servira de base
de travail
ensuite on peut imaginer une évolution
des missions justement de la réserve
naturelle
une adaptation d'opter survoltée
par exemple si le constat ça on le sait
déjà que
elle est peu visible de l'extérieur si
vous êtes sur 50 ans vous n'avez pas un
panneau qui vous indiquent qu'il ya une
réserve naturelle où ça on sait que
c'est un manque en or s'il enquête va
leur révéler et si c'est vraiment un
manque important pour qu'elle soit mieux
connu et bien à ce moment-là en mettrons
en oeuvre cette action par exemple pour
ceux qui souhaitent y participer il faut
obligatoirement et s'y rendre à cette
réserve on peut le faire en ligne dès à
présent il peut faire en ligne dès
maintenant donc sur le site de l'île de
loisirs donc l'enquêté disponible
jusqu'en juillet comme vous l'avez dit
donc toutes les personnes qui sont
venues moment une fois à la réserve
peuvent virer pour une dernière question
sur la fréquentation jusqu'à présent de
cette réserve justement elle est plutôt
stable plutôt satisfaisant elle est
stable ce à peu près 5000 personnes qui
viennent sur la réserve chaque année
dont les métiers confondus la moitié se
représente plutôt des scolaires voilà
donc cesser ces stades depuis des années
on pourrait accueillir un peu plus de
monde
d'où l'importance de participer à ce
questionnaire qui vous servira cette
enquête qui vous servira ensuite de base
de travail merci à toutes les deux
d'être venu sur ce plateau pour nous en
parler et puis on vous renvoie à bien
évidemment vers le site internet de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
merci encore à vous merci après trois
ans de fermeture pour cause de
rénovation le musée du jouet à poissy va
rouvrir ses portes le 11 mai prochain
installé dans une abbaye du 14e siècle
il renferme six ans jouait allant de
l'époque antique à celle des révolutions
industrielles un véritable voyage dans
le temps que nous avons fait en
compagnie d'aurélie ronde
[Musique]
il était une fois un lieu à poissy où le
monde de l'enfance est à l'honneur
trois niveaux sont entièrement
consacrées aux jeux et aux jouets à
travers les différentes époques
il y à 43 ans ce musée du jouet est le
premier du genre à être créés en france
l'idée est venue du conservateur du
musée pédagogique qui était heureux de
ma part et qui était en fait l'héritier
du du musée de jules ferry et du musée
de l'école et c'est cette conservatrice
qui dans les années 70 dans ce musée
pédagogique avait toute une collection
de jouets et elle a cherché un lieu qui
pouvait accueillir cette collection de
jouets pour qu'il soit mieux valoriser
donc nous sommes à peu les héritiers du
musée de jules ferry d' des années 1880
depuis son ouverture en 1976 c'est la
deuxième fois que le musée fermé au
public pour des travaux de rénovation
il faut dire que le bâtiment qui abrite
ses collections de jouets est inscrit au
titre des monuments historiques
nous ne trouvons ici dans la porterie du
prieuré royal saint louis de poissy qui
a été construit au tout début du 14e
siècle par philip lowe lebel en
l'honneur de son grand-père saint louis
qui est né et a été baptisé ici apprécie
[Musique]
restauration des façades mise aux normes
accessibilité ou encore création d'une
extension
le chantier a duré trois ans objectif
que le public soit accueilli dans de
meilleures conditions et ainsi mieux
voyager dans ses souvenirs d'enfance les
collections présentées ont été en grande
partie renouvelé a eu un grand chantier
de restauration des collections de
dépoussiérage et là on présente à peu
près 600 objets sur 14000 qui sont
conservés dans les collections
ils sont en grande partie le fruit de
dons de dons de particuliers
deux collections c'est que nous ont été
légués et sinon c'est des achats les
achats faits en salle des ventes des
achats faits auprès de particuliers
auprès d'antiquaires le parcours
muséographique a été repensée avec une
approche chronologique du jouet une
visite également plus ludique à travers
cette vitrine on peut par exemple
découvrir cette poupée parlante du
second empire
plus insolite encore cette collection de
jouets remontant à l'antiquité prêtés
par le musée du louvre
nous avons déjà là des poupées nous
avons une toupie des osselets le tout
étant introduit par un panneau de
sarcophage sans doute d'une sépulture
d'enfants donc c'est un dépôt d'objets
magnifiques d'une grande ancienneté
un voyage dans le temps possible dès le
11 mai pour ainsi retrouver son âme
d'enfant patrimoine toujours le château
de dampierre en pleine restauration et
ce sont plusieurs trésors qui ont été
découverts notamment les anciens bassins
exécuté par andré le nôtre aujourd'hui
comblé il existe toujours sous terre et
ils vont revoir le jour l escalier
d'honneur du château qui lui
présentaient des similitudes avec celui
de la reine au château de versailles a
par ailleurs été bien identifiés comme
étant l'oeuvre de jules hardouin mansart
on change d'époque avec une journée
mondiale du scrapbooking pardon en ce 2
mai une activité manuelle venue des
états unis qui a de nombreux adeptes en
france aux essarts-le-roi l'association
et scrapping up organise régulièrement
des ateliers mano varaldo ya participé
il ya plus
motif ici qu'ont à moi j'ai utilisé le
motif briques pour coller le petit et
cuire sur le carton vous découpez les
angles je vous ai mis ensuite les
valeurs des papiers à couper ses 10
ennemis par 10 ennemis pour toutes les
feuilles customiser son album photo en y
ajoutant diverses décorations c'est ce
que propose céline lagarde à la tête de
l'association scrapping depuis quatre
ans avec ses ateliers de scrapbooking tu
étale la pâte tout en laissant
éventuellement des petits trous ou pas
comme tu le souhaites tu luttes incline
bien ta petite spatule ne fasse on n'a
pas effacé ont enlevé la pâte à certains
endroits qui a déjà liste une quinzaine
d'adhérentes participent aux ateliers de
scrapbooking l'occasion de coucher sur
le papier au travers des photos et des
commentaires
l'histoire d'une famille là on est en
train de faire un mini album donc le moi
je suis partie sur 12 tentés vacances au
j'ai mes filles qui sont partis en
vacances avec mamie j'ai fait plusieurs
campo najlae j'ai fait un empennage que
j'ai envie
et puis après j'ai fait plusieurs
championnats je préparais mes pages
avant de m
les différentes photos que j'aurais fait
ma mère va me prendre et que je ferai
après deux ans parmi les techniques du
scrapbooking l'embossage h au bar bosser
à chaud donc tu mets ta aversa marx l
encre transparente sur le tampon et
c'est bien tamponné par tous ensuite on
va mettre la foudre tu met de la poudre
un petit peu partout sur ta feuille tu
remets la poudre sur la feuille comme ça
on peut se permettre à dirt vidé après
et maintenant on va chauffer jusqu'à ce
que ça te viennent non venue des états
unis ce loisir créatif à ses adeptes en
france où le fait main et la
personnalisation prime pour les
pratiquantes le plaisir d'inventer
quelque chose de soi même de créer
quelque chose de ses mains et optile
deuxième on peut aussi offert après
derrière des doigts agiles et une bonne
créativité sont nécessaires pour faire
du scrapbooking l'association au scra
pin-up varie ses ateliers et propose
également d'autres créations comme cette
carte aller en 3d donc si on l'a des
pieds en fait en bloquant à l'intérieur
on va pouvoir faire en sorte qu'elles se
tiennent debout
prochains ateliers proposés par scra
pin-up un home déco avec trois cadres
hexagonaux à vos ciseaux nouveau point
sur l'information locale demain dès 18
heures avec le cep suite hebdo de manon
varaldo il sera principalement question
de la biennale d'architecturé de paysage
à versailles première édition en
ile-de-france qui s'ouvre donc à
vendredi
très bonne soirée sur notre antenne
[Musique]